what's fascinating about bezos is very
similar
to musk in the sense that he has
one guiding principle that every
decision goes through so for bezos it's
just if it can enhance the customer
experience let's do it rather than like
profit margin it's just long-term
will this enhance the customer
experience so he says this example
of 10 years from now will people say to
me i won
slower deliveries and a higher cost he's
like no nobody's ever going to say that
to me they're always going to say
i love the fact that it's arrived next
day i love how cheap it is therefore i
double down on that and then elon musk
for as complex as an individual as he is
as intelligent years and how much he
understands
every decision goes through will this
get me nearer to
mars or not yes or no and it's very like
crazy how somebody's
complex sophisticated nuances that has
just one
guiding thing that shapes every single
decision at the scale they're at the
decision you have to make is just will
this enhance customer experience or will
this get me nearer to mars
yes or no
ladies and gentlemen welcome back i'm
joined all the way from dubai
by the man himself mr george mack how
are you i'm not too bad i'm not too bad
how are you
i'm well how could we not be well on the
25th floor
this beautiful dubai marina apartment
there's worse places to do a podcast
isn't it yeah it's a contrast to
newcastle manchester right
contrast yeah and all skype yeah the
year of zoom
finished up in dubai so yeah not not bad
big year 2020 a lot of stuff happened
what's some of the main
insights that you've realized in 2020 oh
it's
a good question um i'm thinking
obsessively
about remote work and the effect that
that has on location
i'm sure even the fact that we're here
right now it's quite quite a good little
a b
test of that yeah but it's going to be
very very interesting because we was
saying like are you bullish or bearish
on people moving particularly the uk
because the uk has very poor weather
um and for me at the minute i've been
thinking if i move abroad what would the
checklist be
if i want to work remote as long as it
has good weather
good time zone and like relatively good
economic social activity
what does the uk have that that you know
what i mean like the uk for me is only
viable for a few months a year and it's
gonna be very interesting to see how
many people leave
on mass or if they do leave on mass
and i think as well that's probably not
just going to be for the uk
everyone thinks the place that they grew
up unless it's unbelievably good yeah is
probably a bit crap
yeah you know everyone's disparaging
about their hometown even if your
hometown was
dubai marina it's just what you're used
to it's not cool or different anymore
so yeah i wonder whether you're going to
get mass swapping
populations from different countries i
think once you've opened that door even
though i do think it will
pendulum will swing back to more and
more office based stuff once you've
opened that door with some people who
are going to refuse to go back
it's very very interesting time to be
living through and whether
because you've got two four processes
that run in your head you've got
obviously a
vaccine comes out things go back to
normal but even then you potentially got
b
which is you have mass migration at
levels you've never seen before
i i was chatting to somebody in the
property business and they said when
covey happened they expected everything
to come tumbling down
but actually they had the busiest two
months that they've ever had it was like
the equivalent of a year
because i've got this idea that i've
been thinking about which is
you have throughout childhood you've
kind of got very clear events you've got
primary school you've got year one
you've got year two or grade one grade
two
and then you go in the uk you've got
gcses you've got a levels you've got
your degree
but then in adulthood all you basically
got is house marriage kids
death i think that's
now an event that exists so like there's
people who are like are pre-coded and
then postcoded so
it causes a lot of behavior change it's
really fascinating to see well think
about what
the uk is trying to do at the moment
they've called it a circuit breaker
lockdown
why have they called it a circuit
breaker lockdown it's because they're
trying to
create a jolt in the system you know
they've just added another little module
in just a little bookmark
and you're correct people live their
life in epochs this is what i learned
from tucker max live your life in epochs
you're the
the sports guy for you like the football
freestyler as a kid
you're the the university student you're
the young entrepreneur you're the young
mother or father you're the the
person who's in a relationship and and
retired somewhere but you know i mean
that's how we break our lives up when
you correct
maybe this is going to be
one of those bookmarks in life for
people
um yeah why are you totally right i mean
we flew out here on
three days no it's too well we just
decided on like 48 hours notice
got a pcr test you drove across
manchester to get a pcr test off some
guy in a pair of tracksuit bobbins he
shoved it down my throat yeah yeah he
did yeah he did you have to pay extra
for that usually and then he did the pcr
[Laughter]
all right so everybody is here for
mental models big pressure
one two and three were wildly successful
online
what have you got for us today yeah well
rocky 4 is my favorite film
so i i'm a big fan of the fourth episode
of things i thought i'd call me some
heat
so late last night i was reading through
uh
poor charlie's almanac which is sort of
charlie munger's
collection of all these essays and i
originally found out this thing from
ben francis the guy who's the founder of
jim shaw i was watching one of his blogs
and he said
within this book portrays almanac
there's a
less an essay lecture on coca-cola
that's like the best thing he's ever
read
um and it's sort of charlie munger he
says in the book afterwards that
he kind of regretted doing it because
nobody really understood it
or it was too complex or it was it
wasn't politically correct
or whatever but when you go through it
it's like jesus christ
so the context of this talk is um
charlie basically says
if you're in 1884 and you have all the
sort of base
mental models or academic principles in
place
and uh uh multi-millionaire george glotz
comes along and he's got a competition
countrywide and says pitch me
um basically a new drinks beverage idea
that if i give you two million dollars
in 1884
by i think 2024 or 2034 it will be worth
2 trillion so how do you turn 2 million
into i believe 2 trillion and basically
charlie says you could have predicted
everything that coca-cola did and how it
succeeded
by just base level mental models
so he goes through and goes like okay
what's my checklist to begin with
how would i explain it to this
millionaire to get investment and what's
fascinating about this is the context is
charlie owns coca-cola or like berkshire
halfway basically own coca-cola now so
you can tell that he's mentally gone
through this and
looked at every single fundamentals of
how this business is highly invested in
why it's being so effective yeah he
basically says this is the issue of
academia they don't teach it like this
so
he said there's five things to go
through when you're doing it so number
one
decide like a big no-brainer question
the big no-brainer stuff
number two use math to help explain the
world
number three inversion so think problems
through reverse number four the best
wisdom is sort of elementary academic
wisdom so he comes on to
like classical conditioning operant
conditioning from psychology
and then number five how do you get big
lola poser
effect where it's all these things tied
together so he says like to begin with
like for the no-brainer side of things
um we are we we're never going to create
something worth 2 trillion by selling
some generic beverage
therefore we must make your name
coca-cola because he says that like
if you called it like george glotti's
drink right you need
in order to get global appeal you need a
name that appeals globally is the first
thing
so this will require developing a
product having universal appeal because
it
harnesses powerful elementary forces the
next thing he goes on to
it goes on to a few more no-brainers but
uses math to explain the world
and this is one of the things i probably
struggle with because maths is
i think the way they teach in school
makes you think it's very very boring
but when you actually understand that
maths is the only thing that's probably
true
when you really think about it um and i
i
i work in obviously the d2c ecommerce
space which is blown up right now
and i'll have calls with founders each
week about like how they want to scale
things
and everybody's very very clear about
their brand values
and their brand guidelines very often
and this vision that they have
but nobody knows their margins nobody
knows nobody knows their ltv nobody
knows the scale they have to hit
why do you think that is um twofold
one i think people of some people just
naturally ignore numbers from bad
experiences at school
and then two numbers
is reality and i think we try and avoid
reality where we can as well
yeah i wonder how much of it perhaps is
just that
you can wing brand values and marketing
and creative ideas if you turn up to a
meeting
and you don't know your ltv or you don't
know your bottom line
you can't just make it up like it's
either there
or it's not that there is no in between
whereas you can turn up to a brand
meeting and be like right
brand values and just yeah yeah yeah
create something on the spot
so i think the show notes the charlatans
get found out
much more with that so what's next so on
that so just
just to sort of hit the the math side of
things home
is so he says here on average uh so
if we had to get to 3 trillion we can
guess reasonably by
2034 there will be about 8 billion
beverage consumers in the world so on
the yet on the numerical fluency he then
breaks down
looking at coca-cola's business model so
the opposite i was saying then where
it's all brand guidelines so if he's
thinking of how do we get to
2 trillion by 2034 he breaks down the
whole market so understands the total
addressable market
so on so on average each consumer
will be much more prosperous in real
terms than the average consumer of 1884.
each consumer is composed mostly of
water and must ingest about 64 ounces of
water per day
this is eight eight ounce servings
therefore if our new beverage
and can flavor and otherwise improve
only 25
of ingested water worldwide we can
occupy half of that new market
therefore he breaks down the numbers we
can sell 2.9 trillion eight ounces
servings in 2034
and if we can net four cents per serving
we will earn 117 billion dollars
annually
which will equate to a net um the
business valued at two trillion
so though that numerical fluency that
like the base
numeracy that people have i'd say
people talk about what's the modern
numeracy i don't think there is a modern
numeracy because it doesn't exist
modern numeracy is the modern numeracy
if that makes sense because we very
rarely ever think in numbers
as a result it seems there that you're
deciding the direction of where you're
going to lay some paving
with that value you can't hit the number
that you want and all the other stuff
the
taste the marketing everything else
that's the
traffic signs that's the road markings
that's the particular way that you
manage the traffic
but in terms of road this is what we
need to hit this is where we're starting
that's where we need to finish
how can we apply that to something which
is a little bit less abstract
than a billion trillion dollar drinks
brand
so well there's a good example one of my
favorite ones that again it's so easy to
notice finger
and sometimes harder to implement it
because you just catch yourself your own
[ __ ] of um
kefra boy uh who work i think he's taken
more
companies public than anybody ever
um he's part of the paypal mafia i think
he was involved at youtube
linkedin square a lot of companies
really good follow on twitter
um and he did a talk at stanford called
how to operate
and he says the biggest thing with like
elite level ceos that he does like the
biggest breakthrough exercises he'll say
what's like your priorities at the
minute and they'll say
number one priority is recruitment
number two priority is
sort of marketing and sales and then
number three is xyz
and he has calls you get them to write
their priorities down and then he gets
them to track their time for a week
and then at the end of the week goes
through and just purely like on a
numerical basis it goes
so recruitment was your number one
priority yet five percent of your time
was allocated to that
so i think even time just as a way of
measuring things is something that you
very very rarely use
how would you class the model that we're
talking about here then so i mean
how you describe this model is just
basic numeracy like basic arithmetic
like taking
principles from mathematics and applying
it because so
few people apply basic arithmetic
i find that when i chat to people who
are starting
brands online the biggest difference
is that there's always one person who
uses basic numeracy
and if they don't if there's not one
there in the team
it never works it never works it's
guaranteed to fail because it makes
sense because that is
if you're trying to build a successful
business it's underpinned by numbers
and if you don't even look at the
[ __ ] numbers you may get a few edge
cases like where it's like a kylie
jenner but even then i imagine she's got
a guy or a girl who's crunching the
numbers yeah
what's next oh so then just moving
through that
he then talks about like operant and
classical conditioning
so if he was looking at he says
how you could explain coca-cola you've
gone through the numeracy you've gone
through the no-brainer questions
and then let's look at like the opera
classical conditioning that you'd use
so number one from opera conditioning
which is basically rewarding people for
behaviors
and then classical conditioning is sort
of pavlov's dog so when they associate
a certain thing so what's fascinating
when like looking at pavlovian
conditioning
he talks about um why and
this is interesting he says you should
not let anybody have the name
cola because as soon as you do you lose
that association with your brand if
other people can start having it they
can hop on your classical conditioning
and it's he does numerous points in here
that coca-cola broke
um and how they almost ruined it so
another example is when coca-cola
changed their recipe
and he's charlie munger lost his [ __ ]
about it i think and he was like almost
killed the company he argues
he says the two things you can't do in
the speech looking at it from classical
conditioning
is one have let anybody have the
trademark coca-cola which is why they
enforce it so hard
um but even then you've got like roller
coal and you've got all these colors
i think the damage that's done to their
their business model is huge
um and then changing the recipe like a
recipe that people have built up and
associated over the years of having this
reward having this reward
the damage that can do and then you
understand like how
interesting slash nuance coca-cola's
business is via classical conditioning
so
they they used he talks about this
speech of you want something that never
has a negative feedback loop
you want something that can never have
negative classical conditioning so
with a good example of of that or maybe
even negative operand conditioning is
you start drinking the drink and the
more you drink it the more sick you get
the drink
but cola removes all sort of taste
memory it's built to remove all taste
memory so people can drink it like water
and just keep ingesting it keep
ingesting it so that's part of one of
these principles for how it can become
so big
is that you can never get sort of a
negative opera conditioning loop going
or a negative classical conditioning
loop going
so it's just constant positive
reinforcement and then he breaks down
okay using classical conditioning using
operant conditioning
do we go for a hot drink or do we go for
a cold drink and he basically looks at
the world going back to numbers looks at
the world and says
it's much easier to provide something
that calls people down
therefore go for a cold drink because on
average people want something that calls
them down
rather than heats them up and people
will drink coca cola in the morning
but hot drinks people tend to drink at
certain periods whereas
the cooling effect people then associate
you so when you're hot and you drink
coca-cola you have that cooling effect
you associate it with something positive
so it's just fascinating about seeing
all these principles intertwined and
even gives examples with the
trademark and with the um
the almost changing the recipe as ways
where coca-cola almost [ __ ] up but
their business model is so good
based on these mental models and these
principles they still are getting their
slash i've got there
do you think how much of this do you
think was thought through and how much
of it is
emerging and look good question well he
argues that you could have thought it
through
and i guess that's because he's involved
in the [ __ ] he is post-rocking the [ __ ]
about but his basic argument is is
these elementary principles still exist
so
even now like let's say for example
you're sitting down and trying to come
up with certain ideas
using those fundamentals will still be
incredibly bad whether you can come up
with obviously there's so much luck
involved
um and there's so i mean you're gonna
look you've got to go through the whole
talk and you see how much nuance there
is to the ways thinking about it
but i would say those elementary
principles of
mathematics um stuff like that you
shouldn't avoid
you saying like we should always avoid
letting people have our trademark
letting people do this
um classical conditioning optimum
condition if you actually then begin to
look at
so many different brands you just see
these fundamental principles
beneath them one of the interesting
stories that i had about coca-cola was
i remember the world's first
portable water distillation
unit about three times the size of a
refrigerator
and they were trying to look at
different ways to get clean water is
this philanthropist guy engineer
and they were looking at different ways
to get it to people and they were
thinking like
how on earth are we supposed to deliver
something like this of this size to
the back waters of africa to
places where there's no roads and as
they're there they sat outside of a
little kiosk cafe you know like a
classic sort of
uh third world cafe type thing it's just
plastic chairs
and they looked and it's got coca-cola
branding above it now like coca-cola has
access to give people coke where they
can't get clean water
um and that really is just notoriety
it's interesting when you think about
that when you really zoom out
you realize that the world isn't that
big
it's massive from an individual
perspective but from a market
perspective
like there's only one coca-cola pepsi
are also
big and there's other drinks brands that
are large like red bull and stuff but no
one's coca-cola
and there's only seven billion people
you can't there's no room for another
coca-cola until you kill that one off
you couldn't have two running in
parallel but you could imagine another
universe in which
there's an earth with 35 billion people
on
is there room for competition that you
know i mean um
but yeah that's that's interesting one
of the mental models that we haven't
spoken about yet is anchoring
yeah and i'm a big fan of anchoring and
i was reading
not long ago about is from rob
henderson's newsletter about how people
can use anchoring to get laid
so can you explain what anchoring is
first and then i'll uh
anchoring um wii u i think we mentioned
it the other day when we was chatting
actually like this example oh yeah
in business negotiation of sort of
almost stating a cert apparently trump
says it's not in the art of the deal so
he'll stay
like a price that's super high to begin
with which means
that then when he let's say for example
he wants 5 million he will stay
10 million because now he's anchored
them around 10 million so when they
barter down to 5 million his actual
price
he's anchored it to this 10 that they
feel like they've got a deal but he's
got what he wanted whereas if he came in
at five
maybe they'd say one because you realize
a lot of these negotiation stuff is just
people putting their finger in the air
and then i mean that ties quite a slight
fork on the idea is this idea of like
reflexivity and how much do you know
what reflectivity is the
model there i think george soros he's
like obviously the huge
like people go mental about he's the guy
behind everything bad isn't he
he is um alex jones arch nemesis right
alex maybe isn't the real one as well
right i don't know
so but he has a very good essay on
reflexivity
um and the best example i got from
reflectivity is let's say you have two
stand-up comedians you have one stand-up
comedian that
um that tells a joke another stand-up
comedian that tells a joke i saw almost
a parallel universe
one where he immediately apologizes for
the joke afterwards
sorry i shouldn't have said that and the
other one who just kind of laughs it
through and moves on to the next one
dave chappelle style
even though they've told the exact same
joke and they're the exact same person
the exact same environment the exact
same crowd
how they react to it influences the way
the crowd reacts
and you can then see that a lot so i
found that like if i have a friend
who's um let's say they're broken up
with somebody and then i'm really
depressed about it
then then like i start reacting
to that if that makes sense and then i'm
like thinking about them more
but if they're just like super you're
just kind of constantly looking at other
people's facial expressions yeah
so that's more like a psychological
mimetic anchoring
exactly in body language that's really
interesting i haven't even thought about
that
but my favorite example of anchoring is
that everyone that owns a restaurant
should have quite a high price platter
as one of the first things that people
see when they look on the menu so some
sort of
special appetizer sharing platter deal
thing
at the top and if you say that that's 45
pounds
yeah the starter that's 11 quid but
should be eight
actually looks like a great deal so
there's a famous example from the
economist that
many people listening may be familiar
with where they play around with prices
and you see
by changing nothing other than the
anchor you can increase the value of the
customer by like 50
which is mad and the example that rob
henderson gave
which again is a psychology one i
suppose is
you can use anchoring to look more
attractive
when you're going out dating so what you
want to do his argument is
is find a friend that looks kind of
similar to you
or is uglier and the reason for that is
that people will use that
around me
they they will look at them
and you as within the same league you
know
like if someone was to say this is how
much the appetizer is
but that car over there is worth this
much money
that kind of doesn't really work you're
not anchoring within the same
category so if you go out with an asian
friend
who's like any pick your attractiveness
level it's like i can't
you don't look asian like so there's no
point in doing it so yes if you want to
get laid
find a friend who looks a bit like you
but is uglier
and you can do that and also there's
i've got some buddies and i'm sure that
you do as well
who will decide to go to live music
events oh yeah
like go to gigs because they look like a
knockoff version of the artist
yeah it's um that only helps if then the
crowd that you find attractive
is that so like my issue with that is my
crowd would be like the
busted mcfly side of things
yeah it's not it's not my not my type
really yeah i know
interesting what you got next power laws
so i wanted to get this up hence wise on
my phone just then so
power laws comes from statistics um
and i'm not gonna try and go through
like the actual like um equation side of
things
but a power law essentially is
it's kind of like the way you can
explain monopolies they're basically
what's the um the line from the uh
film or it's like first prize is uh what
is it like um
first prize is a car of some sort second
prize is a set of steak knives third
prize you fired it's like facebook's a
good example of that
basically a a power law is something
where
um the more you win the more you win so
it's like a non-linear
relationship so um
for example uh the best example of a
power law i've found is
all the you're seeing it now to some
extent where all the wealth like look at
jeff bezos as the power law like the
more wealth he has the more wealth he's
getting
yeah you can easily end up with scenario
where jeff bezos has like 50
of of the world right because he just
keeps compounding year after year
and he's compounding on the compounding
yes who can keep up
and a weird nuance once i've done a lot
previously in social media and
um like different brands marketing etc
and you'll see
with social media managers i have this
thing where
95 of them shouldn't get paid they're
useless they don't add any value if
anything sometimes they're just
taking up your payroll they're posting
that instagram post that nobody [ __ ]
sees apart from them
and you right it's just useless but
for um like five percent of the social
media managers
or maybe one percent of social media
managers like we saw one recently with
like tesco
where it was like saying um if you can
quote tweet this and get zero likes
we'll give you a free meal
and obviously everybody's trying to
quote it can't do it when we checked it
yesterday after about 12 hours i think
it was
000 quote tweets exactly so this is and
then you
you think about the individual behind
that the value that they provide
it they they should probably get a 10x
raise in their salary so all the
all the distribution goes right towards
the end of
the the scale if that makes sense so
that's what
like a power law is and it's very
interesting that yeah the the higher up
you get
the more the rewards are so even if you
look at that sport like the ufc like
the difference betw on salary between
conor mcgregor
and somebody 10 places down from him is
so
astronomical the difference in skill
actually isn't that high but
it's yeah it's fascinating to see how
these power laws play out it's why
in silicon valley they always talk about
how can you get a monopoly
because if you get a monopoly you you
own the world basically
how can people utilize that is it just a
case of
moving quickly that's a good question i
would say
one probably do something that um
it's hard to give like specific advice
for everybody without having so much
nuance to their
their their situation but um i think
from a parallel perspective
of finding out what you s sort of super
unique to you
and then doubling down on that because
you if you can come
talk one percent of something the fact
that the returns are so
so great and so high that that's where i
think the focus should probably lie
i think that makes sense we were talking
about this the other day that um
the difference between the person that
comes first
in the hundred meters and everybody else
in terms of effort
actual time is not a lot but in terms of
impact is an awful lot and
when you get to the far-flung reaches
of performance we spoke about coca-cola
that once you've got that distribution
network you compound on compounding
so yeah i like it because you've got to
think then they can get
a few models of they can get more
network effects so more and more people
the more word-of-mouth marketing you
have
the more word-of-mouth marketing you get
the more um coca-cola bottles you can
produce the cheaper your margins get so
it's like how as soon as those power
laws begin to kick in
you can get cheaper advertising cheaper
products higher quality
like everything everything and it's just
nobody can keep up with that stage do
you um
do you think that there's a
there is a challenge in a society where
we're trying to bring up
people we're trying to have more
not we're trying to have fewer have-nots
and everybody be part of the haves
is there an issue with that with power
laws because inevitably you're going to
end up with winners
and everybody else well i was hearing
alex beckham youtuber talking about
he's very sort of libertarian very
entrepreneurial he was like saying
[ __ ] hate jeff bezos because he's
going to create a scenario where
the rest of the world extremely resent
the rich
because if you actually if you look at
his scale he's obviously not paying any
tax he's got around that
and you're going to have a build-up of
people really hating him but he's
untouchable i try and get jeff bezos
he's got
everything around him he's got on guard
you can't get near him so they end up
going for the moderately rich which is
where he is right
and that's where he's avatar exactly so
um and that's who gets screwed with tax
that's who gets screwed of everything
else so
yeah it's um it's a very fascinating
argument of where
government should intervene universes
where they shouldn't intervene at the
whole libertarian debate versus the
um keynesian debate it's a fascinating
even now like you i think you look at i
thought
a lot about this of you because of covid
and everything else that was known to be
happening even if you don't fully buy
into the whole ai debate
there's obviously going to be some jobs
that are automated and
for me i'd be fascinated to see again
i've not i don't know the numbers i'm
i'm
probably going to avoid on my previous
point but if the government offered a
stimulus right now
to let's say you took the top 50 job
shortages software engineering ux
engineering
everything that's going to be very very
future proofed and there's going to be
more demand for in the future
and offering a stimulus for people to
drop out of their current job
to retrain for a year or 18 months and
pay them and pay the company to do it
of course there's a there's a hit in
terms of taxpayer money there but the
value to that economy
over time would be i wonder if one
country did that
would they be the world's leading
economy 30 years from now because you've
taken because right now let's say for
example you're
doing a regular job that may get
automated soon if you want to drop out
and become a ux engineer you've either
got to do it in your own time
take huge financial risk um and that
as soon as you get to a certain age
that's just almost unfathomable for most
people so
offering that pre-built in would be very
very interesting do you think amazon
should be broken up is it too big
[ __ ] knows like i think um one of the
fascinating ones is sort of
john john rockefeller's uh biography and
you begin to learn about that
how they they um they broke up his
businesses i think because of the
parallel distribution they're going to
end up where
they own everything but what's
interesting from this charlie talk he
says
when you go through the inversion list
one of the things so stuff you should
avoid
is to avoid envy and he says the the
psychology textbooks if you go through
them there's there's nothing on envy
like which is crazy because in the bible
it's like one of the first things thou
shalt not envy and how big of a thing
envy is
he says the way to kind of get around
envy
is to deserve it so people are a lot
less resentful
if you have like a world-class quality
product so he says
um in here third with such with so much
success
coming so when he's talking about
coca-cola's thing we must avoid bad
effects from envy
given a prominent place in the ten
commandments because envy is so much a
part of human nature
the best way to avoid mv recognized by
aristotle
is to plainly deserve the success we get
therefore we will be fanatic about
product quality
quality of product presentation
presentation and reasonableness of
prices
considering the harmless pleasure it
will provide and amazon have kind of
done that so they still got a lot of
envy a lot of resentment a lot of hatred
but nobody's boycotting them from people
from people who are messaging
off phones charged by wires they bought
on amazon exactly and then
and then they're going on to twitter or
they're going onto instagram
complaining about it on an aws server
right
so it's um that that's the thing about
everybody i know who
resents amazon for like the tax side of
things
and how much they're monopolizing
everything still uses them
so it's kind of yeah i i don't know it's
a very interesting question
i've watched uh really we both have
watched some interesting amazon
documentaries
over the last few months and i started
to see
just how beastly their operation is
and he realized that there's probably
going to come a point pretty soon where
that growth and the amount of impact
that they have
especially when they start to ramp up
automated delivery perhaps with drones
or with driverless cars
you'd be able to do that one hour
delivery remote warehouse to customer
without anyone intervening well the
craziest thing about
um amazon is that aws
was or still is profitable as profitable
or more profitable than amazon
and nobody really knows what aws is so
that's another business amazon website
amazon web servers so
anybody almost like netflix for example
will use amazon web server so you can
imagine the amount of bandwidth that
they
they they flow through right so and that
that's basis again what's fascinating
about bezos is very
similar to musk in the sense that
i think people can get so complex with
it and
i understand why but and obviously these
two are geniuses that not everybody can
imitate or mimic but he has
one guiding principle that every
decision goes through so for bezos it's
just
we just care about the customer that's
if it can enhance the customer
experience let's do it
basically if you look at every decision
amazon make if you go back through the
book
um the everything store
every decision he makes is will this
enhance the customer experience rather
than like profit margin it's just long
term long term long term will this
enhance the customer experience
so he says this example of 10 years from
now will people say to me
i won slower deliveries
and a higher cost he's like no no
nobody's ever going to say that to me
they're always going to say
i love the fact that it arrives next day
i love how cheap it is therefore i
double down on that and then elon musk
there's an interview on lex friedman
show where i forgot who it is that
worked with him and he said that
elon musk for as complex as an
individual as he is as intelligent years
and how much he understands
every decision goes through will this
get me nearer to
mars or not yes or no and it's very like
crazy how some of these complex
sophisticated nuances that
has just one guiding thing that shapes
every single decision whereas a lot of
us are like
i've got this part of my life i've got
this part of my life i've got this
interest i've got this
whereas for those two at the scale there
are the only decision you have to make
is just
will this enhance customer experience or
will this get me nearer to mars
yes or no what it makes for when you've
got a chaotic world with an awful lot of
different decisions
you need a simple guiding principle and
i wonder whether
in a world with far too much stimulation
and people with poorly defined goals
goals that they've adopted from their
family from their culture from
what they think they should want
it's not surprising that people struggle
with decision making
because the single guiding principle
that they have
isn't theirs and there's 40 of them
yeah yeah yes they have they're being
pulled in a million different directions
which comes back to direction over speed
right
or just have a direct before you even
think about speed just get a direction
um and yeah that's a
that's a really interesting insight i i
wonder how
people can try and find a guiding
principle in their life
you know because it's too trite to say
just do what makes you happy
you know like you just sit and
masturbate at home all day or
maybe that's your guiding principle
right yeah that would work yeah
um what else have you got for us so this
is what one i've
made up i don't think we've been through
it before we may have done um
so it's called opportunity cost
blindness
so ocb play on sort of ocd
um where this is really hard to explain
about experiencing it but just
how blind we are to the amount of
opportunity cost there is
so often when i found i mean i'm not
i've not had that many relationships but
when you're in a relationship it's
either
them or single them or single them or
single
and it's so hard to actually realize
that it's them or single
or eight billion other people you know
so it's so
but it's so hard to know that
opportunity same with jobs that we'll
know some people where they're miserable
in a job and it's either okay job or
leave job an unemployed job or the early
job
so there's only one opportunity cost but
they forget how
much there is because it's not the law
of large numbers i think we really
struggle
or i really struggle to just comprehend
how much else exists and you can only
see the options that are available to
you
and you only realize that in hindsight
when you're [ __ ] i was like this job
for four years and i was like having
this
argument with my boss every single day
in the shower how much
now i'm in this other opportunity like
how laughable that was and how serious i
took that because you don't even
comprehend the amount of opportunity out
there
so i think almost having a filter of i
right now do not i've got such
opportunity cost blindness i cannot even
fathom how much opportunity there is out
there
and just start from that base level
filter it's probably a smart thing to do
which is
tough though it's very tough it's
reassuring you know when you've got
difficult decision in front of you
but how many times have people obsessed
over what they're going to i don't know
i'm scared about breaking up with the
relationship that i know is wrong or
leaving a job that i don't enjoy or
moving to a new city
or retraining starting
whatever it might be and then as soon as
you do
you realize oh hang on like there's so
many more paths down here i just thought
it was
this or that for instance our trip away
to dubai
we decided to take a trip away i'm like
oh god like i
i don't know whether i should go there's
all of this stuff and you meet a little
bit of resistance
but once you overcome that initial
inertia you realize once you're out here
that
the the one thing that you had written
as go to dubai during lockdown
actually consists of a million different
other routes that are in there
so yeah we certainly bundled together uh
blocks of opportunities into
individual sections which can make for
uh
make for a more simplistic world view in
a way that blinds us
um well i think even um i was trying to
a guy called
adam townsend on twitter and he's got
some fantastic stuff on this
and he talks about how like we're so
addicted to work
like you almost to get over that he said
i just need to take three months out
and you just completely realize like
there's just so much
more there but you you need the time and
the space
and often different opportunities like
since being out here we were just saying
like are you just in a different news
cycle you don't even realize that you're
constantly
this this this news cycle is just in
your software just
running all the time it's just yeah i
don't know about you but when you have
like um
dodgy software on your on your laptop
and you only realize that you've got
loads yeah
it perks the dart web so you've got all
this dodgy and it's just
eating your bandwidth but you don't know
it until you're out of it and i do think
there's so much
opportunity cost blindness that even if
you can pre-build in like
okay i'm not sure if i want to break up
with somebody let's just do like three
weeks over here with my
i'm building these a b tests of like
okay if i try this what happens here if
i try this rap and say
scott adams has this hilarious bit of i
[ __ ] love skylines
he says um in his book the mistake
people make
with seeking jobs is they wait till
they're unhappy in their job to seek it
and the odds of the perfect job existing
when you're ready for it is actually
quite slim
so he says as soon as you should always
be looking at new jobs like just
scheduling like a day a week to just go
is there a new job
does it pay better does it have all this
because you know what the perfect job
for you might be within two months of
starting this job and he says that
that's the key that got him up the
corporate ladder before he went off and
did cartooning
he would just constantly be like what's
the best paying job or what's the best
roi for me personally
and not wait until they're unhappy
because it's so true like people are
wait
three four years and they go right i'm
at breaking point so psychologically
they're done
and now you're searching for new jobs
you've got a two-week window to do it
yeah and the chances of that
two-week window being perfect for you um
it's gonna be slim isn't it interesting
how we map our
model of relationships onto jobs
so in relationship it would be frowned
upon
to still be flicking through tinder and
hinge whilst you're in a relationship
because well you know if this goes wrong
what if something better comes along you
can't really do that and i think people
treat their jobs the level of loyalty
that they have to their job
in a way like that um and i'm not sure
because as a business owner i want my
employees to be loyal
but as a growth-minded individual i want
everybody to maximize their happiness
and utility
and i think if you're a boss
it's probably not a bad idea for your
staff not to be doing that because you
turnover's going to be significantly
lower but as a human i think
yeah that makes a lot of sense we'll be
able to get that solve the
principal agent problem so i guess
another mental model of how do you get
agents to act like a principal how do
you get them what's the difference well
a principal is somebody
who sort of owns it and has direct skin
in the game by the performance of the
thing and has so much care over it
um so somebody who owns the business if
it performs
they make more money if it doesn't they
lose a lot of money and whereas an agent
could just be somebody who's nine to
five
on the clock i get paid regardless of
performance pretty much i've just got to
do the bare minimum to get away with it
um and being able to how do you shift
agents to principals i think naval says
he
he works with like he always wants to
work with one person
so rather than work like a huge agency
it's like how can i just work with one
person because they're directly
responsible
it's so much more difficult to sort of
shriek responsibility whereas there's 10
people in the room it's like
it might be that bit's that guy's job
that fits that so it means the total
thing the outcome of it there's a load
of agents who like
don't really have any personal ownership
over it whereas if i'm working directly
with chris and it fails it's chris's
fault and if it succeeds chris is
chris's success
so it have been able to solve that
principle age which is why so many
startups give
equity i've seen people who even though
the equity game yeah
maybe a few percent of them win like 95
99 never make anything people who will
justify working crazy hours because they
have one percent of the business
so being able to pivot that to a
principal mindset is
a very interesting thing what mental
model do you wish
that more of your friends and family
knew i don't know i don't
wouldn't want to put something on
friends and family um i guess
it inversion say stop hanging out with
me
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah so that's a really tough one i
guess it is so this is the issue i have
with
even like a lot of podcasts and a lot of
advice is
it's just so [ __ ] nuanced and so
subjective to the individual i think
you're seeing this with diet as now
right
i know people who who have nuts and they
die right johnny johnny johnny
whereas i have nuts and i'm fine it's
like
so then to have like one note which why
can't i mental models because you can
take different things for me to
discipline and apply it but when it's
like
you should do x or you should 10x right
i just think that's bollocks because
it's so subjective and nuanced to the
individual like i think we chat about
this previously like
even the word entrepreneur i have an
issue with it because there's
so much like microcosms within
entrepreneurship
joe rogan is so different to jeff bezos
if you put jeff bezos in joe rogan's
shoes with flock if you put joe rogan in
japanese or shoes it would win but we're
told these two people are still
entrepreneurs
for me it feels like it's so different
there's so much
subjectivity out in the world that i
think the only thing when it comes to
advice is
to look at again the fundamental
principles the fundamental foundations
so garyvee has that the dirt and the
clouds the clouds are these big mental
models and the dirt
is so specific and tactical to your
field that
somebody like me going to a machine
learning engineer or chatting to
somebody in physical retail which is
just like yeah there's a few
overlying principles that may help like
compound interest power laws
but there's so much subjectivity to each
individual
that i think is so neglected by
self-improvement in the self-help
sector because it's as nuanced as your
diet it's as numerous as your genetic
code i think
yeah the what everybody's trying to do
is find
a commonality
that permits one piece of advice to fit
many like one-size-fits-all
advice right but i would say i certainly
think that
a lot of my friends and family would do
with
contrast like i i think there's very few
people
what i'd rather talk about myself
because i always feel as soon as i you
start talking about somebody else
you don't know them as well as yourself
whereas at least i know me
very well and i think that you can
easily be in a situation where you give
other people advice
and you're just so detached from it you
see it like so much online i just think
it's yeah
what mental model do you wish that you
could implement oh that's a better
question
um leverage leverage because i'm a
workaholic by trae like
like so like my when i was like 11
my dad bet me up and do 10 kick ups with
a football i then spend
five years training five hours a day
doing kick ups with the football if
anything it was a great
ten to do two five hours to get i got a
lot better i got a lot better um so i
started that came like his little mini
job when i was younger
but that taught me that power of working
hard and
growth mindset so it was super valuable
in that respect
but it also means that i will then try
and do 100 responsibilities and i won't
understand
necessarily the power of leverage as
much so
having more people working for you or
having more code working for you having
more media working for you
is a an unbelievable
tool that i'm only beginning to wrap my
head around
what was that quote that you gave me
about like lazy people make the best
employees because they'll find
shortcuts to do work exactly so you that
that's
like i i've said this before if i could
you know talk about friends and family
i wouldn't give them my any advice or
that side of things it's so nuanced to
them the only thing i'd say is
get working knowledge of zapier because
if you have
the reason why it's because of
leveraging amazing happier i think
zapier if you if again going back to
government stimuluses if
zapier said we will pay for your
five-day lead to learn zapier
if the government said that the value to
the economy would be
the amount of people who right now are
going on emails copying something
putting it in a google sheet
or going from a facebook ad and putting
it into a different document
all zapier is is every major app
connected and this isn't a sponsorship
by the way i'll do this for free yeah
connected i genuinely think
if you talk people about no code skill
the ability to automate things and
almost
become like a like a developer of 18
months in like the space of three days
the productivity for the economy would
be amazing and the first time you have a
zapier
thing that works for you and you can
just see this flowing like we could be
like now i've got zaps running
it's the best thing ever i know once our
chat's done it's to have taken
100 people from different facebook ads
and it's already
automated and sent them an email whereas
previously i'd have to go in get the csv
send that so zapier for me in terms of
an applied mental model of leverage
is the best thing for somebody who can't
code
that's interesting that is really really
interesting
i um i like
i was taught this by my first ever boss
of events company
is outsourcing i know that naval's a big
fan of if something costs
you less than your hourly rate to do it
then either outsource it or just throw
it away
so yeah i think that's a great nuance
point if it's the hourly rate of things
but sometimes i will see it with certain
businesses
that i work with where they outsource
too much
and then they become they become foreign
to it and they just trust people who say
they're experts at it
like one of the best d2c guys i've met a
guy called danny book on twitter
he said to me he went into direct to
consumer
and decided to do all the ads himself
obviously he outsourced like learning
and he does hire consultants to come in
and train them but he said this is the
most fundamental part of the business
i'm not outsourcing it because i've seen
so many other businesses just like
this is the most fundamental part of our
business boom pass it over there
so it's really interesting like how that
balance between outsourcing
but also how do you not get bullshitted
by the people you've outsourced to
so you almost need enough base level
knowledge and maybe that's like
applied mental models so like knowing
basic numeracy so when they say
certain things to you you can check
things off but that's an issue that
charlie talks about
that you need these fundamental mental
models in place because if you do
outsource
you need to be able to have enough
knowledge of that field to be able to
call [ __ ]
otherwise you can just somebody can
sound smart and just trick you
i wonder how many people lie on
the side of the spectrum why they
outsource too much versus how many lie
on the side of the spectrum where they
do
too much i would say based on my
experience
more people are on the latter and that
might be a selection effect from the
type of friends that i've got
but workaholics people from a classic
working class background
they will tend to look to save money
where they can
and on top of that i think the
neuroticism that you have the fear of
something not being done correctly
and the time investment it takes to
teach someone how to be george mack dot
dot x
like writing that manifesto
is such a huge hurdle to overcome and
you think right okay
i could do that and automate my life i'd
have to take three months off of my life
to do that
and i see so commonly in business like
one of the most frequent bits of advice
that i give people is
you should not be doing that that's not
your job that was your job
seven months ago or seven years ago and
for some reason you're still doing
you're still replying to the instagram
dms or you
you're still dealing with the level two
customer inquiries over email like the
first person that it gets up leveled to
is you
after the person that deals with the
customers yeah like no that's not your
job was there
what one specific thing for you where
that you maybe held them for too long
and then delegated it and he was like
oh my god i can't believe how good this
is everything in my business any
specific was there one thing where it
clicked and it was like so the main the
main one
the most stupid thing that i used to do
was set up the nightclub on a saturday
morning
so i didn't miss saturday at my first
weekly event
voodoo for 204 weeks so just shy
of four years and the only reason i
missed like the 205th
was because i had a chest infection that
had me bed back like strapped to the bed
bed bound
other than that hungover fresh ill
what every different iteration of life
for
four years i was there outside the same
club for four years and i used to spend
my saturday
morning into afternoon eleven till two
or three
setting up the club and that was just
hanging up inflatables anyone who's ever
been to a nightclub and noticed the
extra decor
most of that make sure the decks are
right do a sound check piss off
you could have paid a couple of students
30 quid each they would have got more
value out of it because they need the 30
quid more than i need to lose three
hours of my time
and i would have retained because i was
working every night as well
but for some reason i was terrified that
the cable ties were going to be put on
wrongly
oh well if the cable tie isn't that way
and it came from a catastrophic mindset
that i presumed if the cable ties were
on wrong
that would be the beginning of the
avalanche that collapsed the business
it's borne out of working in an industry
which is very fickle very very fast
moving
everyone knows what it's like like the
cool spot to go to last week
is nobody even goes there this is like
kovid just hits
one venue at once and everybody
dissipates
and that creates a level of ambient
anxiety
that pervades through the the source
code of the industry
and that was maybe uh made worse by my
own
um personality and when all of that got
piled together
yeah i i struggled to let go of so much
stuff
setting up the venue was one of them
doing the accounts was another one i
didn't need to sit and watch the
accounts
oh my god here's another one so we used
to have the way that the guest list was
set up for our events
i used to take the plus number so george
mac plus three
i used to take the plus number and put
it in another column why
why on earth like i don't need a fully
justified number column
it makes no difference it's being seen
by one guy in the front door
and that guy's me but i don't need to do
this but i would take a
guest list with 300 names 400 names
doing 1500 people a night
and i'd be going through i wouldn't have
done a macro for it i wouldn't have like
automated it i would do it manually and
it took until that one day and i was
like
what am i doing so that very much i
think is sweating the small stuff
and obsessing over things without
perspective one of the problems of being
an entrepreneur or a business person or
someone that has a hobby that you care
about is when you're this close to it
when you are in the dirt
very hard to get perspective and look at
where should i
be where am i adding the most value
right opportunity cost blindness again
isn't it really that you don't have the
ability to step out and it's interesting
that the reason why
the only reason that happened to you is
because you said what you ended up in
hospital you got ill
it's crazy that you get to the stage but
imagine that never happened you'd
probably still be doing it right
you're probably gonna be here right now
like it's it's weird
it's very wet so maybe the the nuance
between what i'm saying
don't delegate too much what you're
saying people need to delegate more is
and there's that
i think i don't know if it's parish or
about who but
if it involves judgment or creativity
or and it's the highest priority thing
then have 100
obsessive ownership over it and if it's
something that doesn't involve that
if it's just like manual tasks or stuff
that you can train somebody for then
ourselves immediately
one of the things i've been thinking
about a lot this year is mental
masturbation
so i think people who enjoy
the mental models world can often become
too cerebral
around finding their solutions for it
you can think that
all the answers to your questions just
lie at the bottom of being able to
recite for charlie's almanac yeah yeah
yeah
and that's the compliance and the
ability to deploy that
actually makes all of the difference it
is multiplying by zero
if you're not able to do it so how can
people that are listening perhaps you
know fourth episode deep in this
particular series
have you got any ways that you ensure
that you don't just
mentally jerk off with this sort of
stuff and that you actually try and
apply it
so hard again without knowing like how
do you so subjective it's a good
question it's definitely something
i've got a lot better um i think
i think it's much easier when you've
committed to certain things and then
there's people that hold you accountable
to them so if it's just you working
alone on a project it's much harder
but i think as soon as you're like quite
public of that you're working on
something or you've got a partner to be
working on something or you've got
employees you have to do it for then
i don't know you can't just go like all
right guys i want to turn up to the
monday morning meeting because i'm going
to go and read for five hours like
you've got to then maybe schedule you're
reading for a certain time but then you
have to execute so i think that's great
and then i think going back to numbers
as well i think
you just can't shoot numbers so if for
example um
i guess you'll know this better than me
but like the gym side of things you
can't cheat the numbers so
if the numbers aren't changing i.e
whatever your metric is whatever you
decide on as your metrics whether that's
money or whether that's i don't know
weights lifted in a gym or whether it's
calories consumed or
whether it's number of times i'm seeing
my parents revenue
top line sales whatever you can
basically i know this sounds very like
um people feel that you can sometimes
over quantify life but i'd say on the
most part people don't do it enough so
if you quantify things and it doesn't
improve
start changing variables i think that's
it again you do
the whole the whole thing about that
answer there like the whole mental
masturbation if you then start mentally
masturbating over the answer it's just
the [ __ ]
just like it's a hamster and i think so
i think get a number
of a thing that you want to change and
throw variables in
does the does it change if not why
change the variable again
and just keep doing that and then just
keep a track of that number so
it's very simple has the revenue gone up
has my time spent on this activity gone
up has my elo score of chess.com gone up
yeah has it it has indeed nice yeah nice
right we are going to play a game of
bull or bear
and bull or bear is something we've been
doing in our whatsapp chat for a little
while which is where one of the
guys will post anything and
everyone will reply with an emoji so you
can play you can play along at home
uh bull or bear faith in the voting
system oh
look um faith in the voting system so
all that's really hub
i'm bare on the way it currently is i'm
bull on the way
my way is what's your solution so well i
thought about this
talk about an elephant in the room 2020
will be remembered as the year
where pens and paper were redundant
unless it was deciding the most powerful
person in the world or
people counting numbers repetitively on
low-wage jobs were redundant
unless it was deciding the election
imagine if you go to your bank
and let's say you have twenty thousand
pounds in your bank ten pounds let's say
you have ten thousand pounds in your
bank
and you go how much money do i have my
bank rather than having it automated by
computers
and robots doing it for you it's a guy
in the back room he goes right give me a
give me overnight and he goes there
pound coin by pound coin going oh one
pound one pound one pound
wrote 10 p 10 p 10 p and he comes back
with that number that number will be
false
there's no way about that whether you're
a trump founder by default whoever you i
don't know whatever
country you're from having the system of
people counting things
and it being done by pen and paper is
[ __ ] ludicrous
no matter your side it is wrong like the
number will be wrong
yeah because when they recover the only
reason the only reason it could be right
is by the errors on one side fixing the
errors on another
like if you if you somehow one in a
billion trillion
chance they were all correct it wouldn't
be because they were accurately counted
it's because
lattices on one side would end up so
what's your solution um
blockchain yeah so it's it's so obvious
right you can just everyone has an
encrypted key
it you submit it therefore you can go
you can everybody can go back and see
there's
stored in a blockchain nobody can
interfere with it the amount of votes
that will go up as a result of it
because people can do it from their
smartphone rather than having to go to a
polling station and
catch something you can't cheat there's
no it's very hard for electoral fraud to
happen obviously
whether the technology's there you have
to be able to do it the issue is very
few governments and
they're they're so backwards in their
thinking but that
seems inevitable right it seems so
inevitable after this year that
you can't have pen and paper any why is
pen and paper involved why are humans
still counting numbers it's ridiculous
so let's say that pen and paper gets
disbanded
yeah but blockchain doesn't get brought
in are you bearish or bullish then let's
good i mean
i so if you want to go down a rabbit
hole the best guy
content he's called a guy called george
hopps and he hacks into he's the first
guy i think to hack into the iphone the
first guy to hack into the sony
playstation
so he'll hack into anything and you'll
show examples of
how easy it is to hack in to your iphone
just turn your camera on and start
recording you
um you can hack into it shows how you
can hack into cars
so if you think the government i t
team bear in mind like in the uk the
government
nhs is the largest buyer of fax machines
in the world
how backwards they are i reckon even i
have a bit of html and five hours on
code academy could probably hack into it
so
i'm pretty bearish on that unless they
bring the best people in so i still
think it's gonna be a [ __ ] show for a
while yeah
that's not great uh brian rose for
london mayor bearable
massive ball yeah massive ball are you
yeah are you really i don't know
i think is he his third favorite and um
i know you're probably about
i mean i yeah i don't really have an
opinion i probably said bull
kanye 2024 bearable
bear because he'll have to be if he
could win republican a
democrat and i'm i'm a bit bull because
then i might do a trump but i think
he'll have to be independent i
just don't see that happening anytime
soon yeah the thing about kanye is that
going on rogan
and getting asked hard questions and
then sitting in silence for 30 seconds
like i so many people are seduced
by artistic capacity in one domain and
presuming that it means genius
across them all like there's not that
many polymaths out there
and they're they're kind of like
bizarrely they're quite easy to spot
like you hear eric speak you're like
yeah yeah yeah
he'll he'll move seamlessly from
cephalopods to classical
latin music to like complex physics to
whatever stephen wolfram you'll hear him
move between
crazy different areas it comes back to
that kind of blagging it
mentality fashion's very easy to black
as well like fashion is
built on trouble it's built on
reflectivity it's just how people react
to things so
yeah i listened to that rogan thing and
my mind was a pendulum of genius
madman it would just switch back and say
it's so hard to say right it's so hard
to knock your success at the same time
uh bearable sex robots
um i mean
probably probably bull i think is the
way it ends up
uh as costs go down the only thing that
i can see
the only thing that happens potentially
before then is the
printing viruses i think is probably
inevitable
so okay so you get a virtual sexually
transmitted infection no no no i just
think we could get i think we could just
get killed off before then but then
again if we do have a printed virus
scenario where
so george hotspur is this a
nanotechnology thing
i was listening to george hot so he does
this five-hour python stream and he's
just coding things and he's just like
the most intense man ever
and he's talking about he'll pull up
google really fast because how many base
pairs are in the corona virus ten
thousand base pairs because how much
does it cost to print a base pair and
it's like three dollars
because so it would cost me thirty
thousand dollars to stop the chrono
virus could you imagine where the future
technology's gonna be and he just kind
of looked at the camera like that
i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah he's so right his
knee like if the 3d printing technology
is going to go down you can access the
genomes of all these things and just
take the base pairs
but then again if we all keep doing
these pandemic lockdowns that sex robots
are going to
sex we're about to go one of the
interesting things i read it's
uh jeffrey miller's other half
the woman who's scientist
on uh sentientist on twitter and she was
talking about how
in a society an increase
in freely available sexual satisfaction
actually turns down sexual assaults
and overall aggression and the reason
for that
is that most of the sexual assaults are
born
out of people feeling like they can't
win in the normal game
but by gaming the system it doesn't
matter that
you couldn't win in the real world but
you get to win in the fake world and
that doesn't fix it it's like
we're able to hack into our own
programming fairly easily
and that's one of them watch a movie and
see how that works yeah
porn does exactly the same thing uh
final one
remote working for the majority of a
workforce
let's consider here before you go into
it
people who need
contact around others who require that
working environment
it's tough i'm thinking about this like
hiring and
do be higher so on one hand if you hire
a remote you have access to so much more
talent and sometimes a more affordable
price so i said remote work
is the best thing possible to happen to
talented people in the developing world
and the worst thing possible to happen
to
talentless people in the developed world
because like
there's so many things where there's
somebody in another side of the world
that can do it for
a quarter of the price 10 extra work
ethic
and 5x their brains so
i'm pretty bullish on it certainly for
the developing world and the wonders
it's going to do with flowing money out
there
but i do have concerns that for people
who are
talentless in the development of i know
talentless is a strong word but
aren't as skilled in the developed world
what that does for them
yeah so i think it's the pendulum is
going to obviously shift a bit
further back to where it was but it's
never going to go back that way just
because there's some people who i know
that will refuse to take a job that is
in an office now
really yeah there's definitely people
who will um i think the ideal
there's talk about this where like these
big tech companies who are uh
shutting down their offices are now just
having like we work spaces that people
can drop in do meetings
but then they live around the city i
think that's probably more likely but
i said this when um when all these tech
companies start working from home i go
that's a hacker's [ __ ] dream
because now you've got so many people at
home wifis and alexa devices that you
can hack into and then you look at the
twitter hack that happened
they're all working from home and the it
came i remember at the time it's been
definitely
you know where it dreams later it's a
couple kids right um
but it came from i think um obviously
it's the classic they're pretending to
be security and they got in that way
but they said that it was way easier
because of the fact they were working
from home so if you want a trillion
dollar idea
cyber security for remote work
christ yeah i mean what what
the the level of security that you have
that gets built into offices that's part
of the thing that people don't realize
that
you just presume your offices the brick
walls the air conditioning in the
cafeteria downstairs
but it's not it's all of the
infrastructure that permits you to do
your work in a secure way as well
that logs stuff that's got cloud storage
it's constantly updating that
you know yeah you you really correct
that's terrifying
there's probably some industries in
which remote working just needs to
like let's not let's not decentralize
the pentagon
you know let's not have the nuclear
football be available on an app
on like trump or biden's phone or
something like that
oh look that was awesome dude i'm so
glad you're out here with me i'm really
happy to go through this as well
i think if people are keen i reckon that
we can do
some much longer episodes playing
bearable
and 101 get some submissions through
yeah if you're a bull on barrel ball
send them
the bullets if you're better to send the
bear emoji yeah that's it
where should people go they want to
check out your stuff and also what
you're doing now people might want to
know
where what's happening in your life give
us the elevator pitch yeah so
mainly uh blockchain sex robust
no so um if you want to find me
twitter's usually the best place on
there a little bit
um it's george underscore underscore
m-a-c-k
um and then in terms of myself primarily
e-commerce d2c
agency so paid social shopify builds
customer acquisition
text message sms and then looking at our
own products as well so if you've got
products
you want to scale or you should have a
conversation that's there peace dude
it's always a pleasure to have you here
thank you to everybody for tuning in let
us know about bearable i think it's a
really cool idea and i want to do more
of them and it's funny
and yeah we're gonna grab another coffee
a little bit of sun
doing afternoon work looking forward to
it peace
you